hello hey guys this is a podcast we're
doing called lifeline and it's also a tv
show if you're watching it on your tv a
lot of people watch the podcasts on tv
on youtube and stuff stream it to their
tv and that's it's still a podcast right
you watch on your tv so it's not really
a tv show anyway i'm crystalia and this
is matt daley natalie yeah you say it
though it's an ode to the old love line
yeah in the 90s which was the [ __ ] we
loved that it was mostly about sex
advice but we're going to give all sorts
of different advices you say advices
which is like arnold schwarzenegger and
pumping iron when he when he says he get
all different advices i give a bunch of
different advisors he comes to me for
advices and the thing i say about this
show is it's the first podcast about you
if you got a problem or you got some
kind of question in life or advice that
you want you drop a video to us if it's
like super secretive [ __ ] you don't want
anybody to know you could take a video
your face is in darkness so nobody sees
you you've got the voids like this yeah
like you know you can do a british
accent so we can't tell whatever it is
you're at a crossroads if you've got a
conundrum in your life mm-hmm just
learned the words
just a thesaurus right yeah and i'm
fitting them into this promo right now
anything from really [ __ ] up ones to
really straightforward simple ones i'll
give you good advice chris will give you
other advice i give a really good advice
i give crazy good advice
do you yeah i do ask so many people well
we'll find out when we do the show
should i give up my day job and pursue
my dreams
should i save my money better i'm
worried that my partner is having an
affair what's the best way to do it gas
is really expensive do you think i
should get rid of my car should i kill
my father you know what i mean like okay
yeah see the thing about that one is the
answer is always going to be no you
should not kill your phone not
necessarily dude because you could be
like hey my dad's here and he's got a 12
gauge to my head he's my dad but should
i [ __ ] kill him to save my own life
what's up what's up fam my dad's about
to shoot me he's got a 12-gauge on the
side of the [ __ ] shop
just a day later you know we give him
advice and he's still
[ __ ] flies in his [ __ ] we're rip
roaring and you're dressed like an art
teacher and that's fine no you know who
[ __ ] wears this and our teacher
besides me who
and maybe an art teacher is [ __ ]
haley bieber
so maybe you could even get fashion
advice from me probably same size too
because wow
but i'm saying no but not because you're
small because the oversized fit is the
thing now play with party where's it too
playboy who the [ __ ] is playboy carter
okay it's a rapper dude what playboy
cardi's a person yeah he's a rapper dude
he
there's a cardi b what is but what is
cardi what is party b and then playboy
cardi there's a lot of lil little john
what is cardi cartier i don't like that
well i don't like it either dude i have
no idea what he looks like i just found
out what gunna looks like and he dresses
horribly he dresses so he would never
wear this he dresses always like there's
a flood but also he's at the beach
somebody the other day i was wearing
this and somebody said oh hi waldo
no that's not guess if my blood boiled
or not yeah because it's not correct
enough but you were carrying a bunch of
books they were talking about right
yeah the new show is lifeline subscribe
be ready for the first episode and this
is the new studio and it's dusty
yes dude it's too dusty
[ __ ] yeah the studio's too dusty
that's too loud i was liking it until
you did that
that's the most respectful thing i've
ever known you to ever do
i'm respectful
subscribe like let everybody know dude
yeah we're coming for you lifeline
advices and advices and yeah and don't
murder your father
[Music]
hello
[Music]
hello